one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday Jackson
clotter back in studio the girls are at
it again the girls are what they're at
it again and we're gonna make you laugh
maybe it will make you cry I don't know
what's gonna happen but we're gonna have
a good time my kind of improv singing
skills like songwriting on the Fly have
really improved since I've been spending
so much time with Harry yesterday I
wrote like a banger for Harry yeah that
was better than yesterday yeah yesterday
I was using the Little Einstein guitar
and I just want to say Little Einstein's
an amazing company their guitar sucks no
you're right I can't get creative you're
wrong for that I can't get creative
you're wrong for that the guitar is so
good don't listen to her she has doesn't
know no the drums are amazing little
Einstein drums I think the guitar is
better than the drums and at home we
have like a little guitar with strings I
guess it's like a little ukulele which
was always fun but then here we got the
electric Einstein electric guitar we
actually have a different electric
guitar at home too it's like in the
shape of a dog it's it's fun me it's
Unique okay it's fun though this is the
best guitar for kids little Einstein I
don't agree it it doesn't spark
creativity
you're wrong for that I'm just saying
you're wrong
um it is 1 000 degrees in New York today
it is satanic it's disgusting honestly
had I known it had been so hot I would
have told you not to come into Studio I
can't even imagine how uncomfortable you
are I was already uncomfortable just
like being pregnant right now
um so many different
ailments now when you were thinking like
me and Zach we want to try for baby
number two because I think a lot about
the timing yeah so tell me when exactly
you conceived so I can avoid that month
like the [__] plague because then you
are your most uncomfortable in the dead
of Summer end of November all right
girls we're waiting we're not getting
pregnant in November but like okay if
you got pregnant in January you would be
like seven eight months in six seven
months what month would I have to get
pregnant to avoid the summer entirely I
want to be Timber okay because fine I'll
be postpartum in the summer okay
September September yeah
okay like that's not it's not gonna work
for me or I need to move to Antarctica
well you should move there anyway I
completely agree you guys it's still
thick and it smells like this is really
truly the worst time to be alive in New
York City like it's so hot my thighs are
even right now like the air is on in
here it's not enough no the air is
barely on in here we are just two sweaty
Oaks trying to do our best I'm not
sweating right now but like I fee my the
air feels thick like it's hard to
breathe but it was already hard to
breathe so true well your hero seriously
uh uh I'm glad I decided to wear my hair
up though that was more out of laziness
because it was like I was gonna I washed
my hair last night I was gonna do it
today I'm like why would I do it for one
show yeah it takes so much out of me to
do my hair right now are you sitting Are
you standing when you're doing it been
standing but I think we gotta get to a
chair if I were to do it again I would
sit but then like I can't see the mirror
it's just problematic so but it is but
it is you look great you look so cute
thanks I'm so happy to be back in studio
there's really nothing quite like it
there is nothing quite like it and we've
got a gorgeous show yesterday was such a
long episode we didn't even get to Deer
toasters and we had three amazing
submissions so we're gonna do that today
we're gonna talk about the stories
use three words to Define today's
stories topical I would hope
varied
maybe perhaps layered
we shall see we shall say that's to be
discovered the meaning we find behind
the story if we can find meaning yeah
random would be the third and you think
we're just gonna like sit here and soak
up each other's awesomeness you think
don't do we ever do anything else no no
so before we dive in let's talk about
ourselves like kind of the most
important thing going on right now is US
yeah and I would say the most important
thing going on today aside from the
toast of course is the new episode of
the redheads that drop yes that's so
true we recorded last night it is so
long because we were loving talking
about the book we also like shared all
the other books that we read this month
we were like nearing an hour and a half
it was craziness but it was a really
great episode I don't want to spoil
anything for the redheads I don't
however
Jax kind of learns a new language Jax
learns a new language it's true the book
is said to run the deaf Community yes
and they teach a little ASL in there and
Jackie's over here spelling Bruno's name
do it
I got that one like instantly yeah that
one's pretty easy Jackie is taking me a
little bit longer but I've also only
been practicing Bruno which is fun yeah
I know
did I do it sort of almost tell us what
she spells yeah yeah yeah as hell is
[__] hard it is it's like not what
you would think like oh love heart like
no some things are like me you like
there are some but some of the gestures
are not as obvious as you would think
that they could be you know yeah it's
more layered if you read the book you
learn a lot of gestures but you also
learn a lot about just like ASL how it's
very
um Dynamic like it includes your your
shoulders your head tilting your
eyebrows your facial expressions like
when your eyebrows go up that's a
question asked right it's kind of like
choreography yeah it's it's a full body
experience and I think that some people
are like better storytellers in ASL
because they really gesticulate a lot it
was reminding me of the clip of the ASL
interpreter from the Super Bowl right
well that's why like so many like of the
the bet you could be like a better sign
language
speaker than others and that's why the
best go to like the Super Bowl yeah
that's just like you could be a better
order than either it's a better public
speaker just more compelling that's like
anything any language it's so exciting
that the redheads are back the redheads
are back with a great episode so
definitely check it out and even if you
didn't read the book but you want to
hear us chit chat we do a summary at the
top of the show it gets harder the more
pregnant I get because I talk for such
long minutes periods of time on the
redheads and by the end everyone's like
are you okay do you have to edit out
your heavy breathing no it's not heavy
breathing but it's just like I'm
catching my breath all the time kind of
like Kelly Clarkson we decided that next
month someone else is gonna do the
summary and you know what like why not
let them like why does it have to be me
every time it's a lot of pressure
speaking of catching my breath I have
finally like now in the last couple of
days sat down and really listened front
to back to Kelly Clarkson's album okay
which I hadn't done yet and that's a
shame on me but I've been realizing
tonight speak now comes out and I'm
gonna be listening to that for the next
month so I need to get all so I listened
weirdly to Miley Cyrus's Endless Summer
education a few times and it's literally
amazing I can't believe I just like
literally didn't care and I've been
listening to Kelly's it's so good like
you can catch me playing cowboy in the
wild wild west like it's so good I'm
obsessed it's so good I've been
listening a lot too while I get ready
this morning I I did something different
I wanted to hear like the new music I
also thought it was Friday so today's
giving Friday energy yesterday was
Monday and today's Friday like it makes
no sense so true I'm just like is the
week over yet right because it just
feels like it's so short it should be
over but it's not so I was listening to
my new music Friday the new Old Dominion
album I was listening to I gotta do that
like maybe Webb has a new song So Good
so good it's you know summer everyone's
releasing bangers yeah tonight's like
gonna be so exciting there's so much on
the horizon for for the swifties yeah I
guess tomorrow will be all about speak
now TV also Kardashians I'm gonna watch
today me too I really can't put into
words how how this schedule is not
working for me inconvenient and annoying
the new not new but like ever since they
moved to Hulu like how they drop their
episodes at midnight like because you
know all these articles come out about
the um the episode and like what
happened in it because like they send
out screeners to like you know E news
and everything so you really can't even
watch it like if you have a job like you
go to bed and you wake up like you can't
watch it till literally 24 hours later
yeah it's so annoying like I really we
never ever ever recap Kardashians on
Thursdays no how could we right and then
by Friday it feels old I would have to
stay up till 1am right and we're not
doing that we're little girls that's
crazy talk it's so annoying
yeah so I'm excited to watch though I
think that
the sit down between court and Kim is
this episode right even though like they
made it seem like it wasn't yeah they're
kind of dragging it out but yeah I'm
lapping it up me too but that's kind of
the theme of the new Kardashians on Hulu
like dragging things out dragging things
out everything's a commercial for their
brands which by the way I kind of like
that part like I do find especially with
like skins like I feel like not enough
people talk about how skims has become
like literally even though I'm like
about to get blacklisted I have to tell
you a story I told you yesterday right
yeah so I placed an order I love skins
like I cannot I'm gonna skip this bra
right now oh and I just want to say like
this isn't like clinical information or
anything but I was having crazy back
problems and I literally got brows from
skims and I don't want to jinx it but
it's been like weeks and I haven't had a
single back problem like I think maybe
I've been wearing the wrong bra from for
years for sure but you also have been
doing physical therapy no I haven't I
literally stopped you've also been
walking more I have I have there's a lot
of things but sure so I
I place an order for skims and I you
know what actually I really don't want
to tell the story it's like long-winded
and boring I love you better get that
like yeah and you know I know it's gonna
be one of those stories where like say
the end and like No One's Gonna realize
the story's over and it's like like so
yeah you know we usually do a good job
of of height you don't really tell bad
stories but if you did like I don't even
think we would notice I just think like
I'm not in the mood to sit through a
story about your customer service
experience no I know and I don't really
feel like there's anyone worse on the
planet than people who use like their
platform to complain about
um
small customer service mundane customer
service things no like if I see someone
like on Twitter or on Instagram stories
like adding Delta I can't believe my
flight was delayed like what are you
gonna do about this literally unfollow
like I just think there's like there's
no worse way to use social media than to
complain about customer service if
you're like a person with a platform
yeah I think some you know regular folk
will be like at Delta like what's going
on and they actually use it for real
customer service not to just like
complain and try and like shame a brand
because you're an influencer or
something right I hate that [__] hate
and I think when it's um lay people who
do it sometimes like those things go
viral because it's such a crazy thing
that they've experienced right uh but
influencers are typically just
complaining about things that people
like just experience every day like
nothing's perfect no brand or service is
perfect and like just move on just like
[__] off I literally hate [__] like that
yeah
I'm glad you did as well and I guess we
could get into the stories and get those
off of our chests I guess I was gonna
share that um my birthday's coming up
yeah I know it's on Monday and I'm
taking the day off because I'm not the
type of person who works on my birthday
um but that's not the point of what I
brought it up well I brought it up is
like you know every year
without fail like the week of everyone
said Claudia what are we doing for your
birthday I'm like I'm not there a month
before when we were with my friends I
think when we had brunch like a month
ago they were like Claudia are you doing
something for your birthday because like
I want to block off that weekend now and
you're like no I don't want to do
anything they're like you always say
that I do and I but I said to them like
she's not gonna plan if she plans
anything it will literally be the day
before so do it that way you will yeah
and so just major shout out to Jackie
and Ben who yesterday were like enough
enough
and they planned me a little dinner
party and I'm actually really excited
about it so that's really excited too I
just want you to know the my the way I
came at it was not from like an enough
standpoint you actually like wouldn't
even you don't even realize that you
wouldn't even let us like plan it for
you I texted Ben so that he and I could
plan something together like for you
maybe God forbid a surprise or something
oh I didn't know that was an option yeah
and then you kind of just like took over
planning but that was not my intention
like I was trying to plan it for you
make it nice that's completely Fair
and I reached out to Ben I guess he just
told you everything I was saying he did
he did and he kept saying like we might
go away I'm like I know her she's not
going away well the I feel like the you
know the the most important thing here
is that like we now have a plan and I'm
excited and we have a good plan yeah
it's gonna be great I need to get an
outfit but I'm excited about it yeah
that's because we were talking about
your birthday yesterday on the show and
I was like she deserves a little Soiree
she's not gonna plan something for
herself nor should she because she like
hates to be the center of attention I
think it's on me to do it no I love that
thank you for me why not you with a
Sprinkle of Ben stopper celebrity right
and you know Ben one two three got the
place booked right that's so bad right
so I think we made a really good team
I'm excited about it but you were not
meant to like make your own invitation
and stuff like that I was like trying to
do it like so no like I'm I'm good with
how we landed yeah I feel good about it
me too
that's all that matters that's true so
now without further Ado I keep feeling
like this is the last show before your
birthday but it's not it's not um also
like seriously I'm so [__] hot like
I'm not put your hair up I know
satanic outside and it's like
the windows are bringing like the hot
air in here yeah it's not much better in
here how does that look like okay okay
it's just too hot without further Ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by Thrive Cosmetics five Cosmetics is a
fabulous cosmetic brand and there's a
million reasons to love it but I would
say the number one reason is because
their stuff is really good I'm wearing
the mascara today
um the mascara is the best mascara on
the market I use it in every single one
of my get ready with me is it's that
green tube it's called the liquid lash
extensions mascara it is more than 25
000 star review five star reviews for a
reason it mimics the look of lash
extensions am I okay without the
damaging glue or Salon prices they use a
proprietary tubing formula which means
that it wraps around each of your lashes
as you apply it and it'll drastically
lengthen and Define your lashes from
root to tip my lashes are like my least
favorite part of my glamor tea and I
have the worst lashes they're so
straight I can never get them to stay up
but when I curl them and use this
mascara it is I just I promise you like
I know this is an ad but I use mascara
every single day I use a lot of other
products too but that's definitely my
favorite
Jack and I love their um hydrating lip
tints because like summertime like we're
all licking our lips it's so hot we need
like hydration but we also want to look
stuff we need a tint you want to look
alive so that's the um hydrating the
sheer strength hydrating lip tint the
colors are really pretty it goes on
really well it lasts a long time they've
just fabulous products they also have
waterproof eyeliner eye brighteners
um and it's certified 100 vegan and
cruelty free it's made with Clean Skin
loving ingredients it has no parabens no
sulfates no lathylates and it's all
without compromising performance and
it's called Thrive Cosmetics for a
reason a part of their mission is every
purchase supports organizations that
help communities Thrive so you have to
try Thrive Cosmetics to see for yourself
right now you can get an exclusive 20
off when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com toast that's
c-a-u-s-e Medics so
thrivecosmetics.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
Mattress Firm temperature is a common
sleep disrupter and one of the things
that could affect your quality of sleep
I mean hello it's satanically
demonically hot outside and we're all
like you know sleeping on top of the
covers because it's so hot Mattress Firm
has got you covered their sleep experts
get over 200 hours of training so they
can pair you with the right mattress if
you sleep hot at night some of us sleep
hot year round some of us only sleep hot
in the summer we all are different some
of us are pregnant sleeping mad hot so
true so you can chat with a sleep expert
in store or online with Mattress Firm
you take their online mattress match
your quiz and you'll be matched with a
high quality mattress at every price
point from top brands like tempur-pedics
Stearns and fosters Serta purple
Beautyrest sleepies and more if you're
looking for a convenient mattress in a
box they can also help you with that
Mattress Firm has more than just
mattresses they have cooling sheets and
pillows that help regulate your
temperature because the last thing you
want to worry about is just being hot
also the last thing you want to worry
about is torturous mattress delivery but
Mattress Firm offers free and fast
delivery so the difference between
having a great night's sleep and a bad
one is everything the right mattress
matters and Mattress Firm will help you
find yours so mattress firm's July 4th
sale is a place to find high quality
mattresses at every price point this is
a sale if you want to upgrade to a
cooler mattress and accessories shop in
line shop in-store or online at
mattressfirm.com I got my mattress firm
mattress when I moved into this
apartment it's maybe been five years I
got it I think it was like a Labor Day
Sale I always shop Mattress Firm when
it's like a big you know national
holiday they love federal holiday just
like us they do love federal holiday I
have the best mattress it's in the best
condition I feel like it cleans really
well like I always get like spray tan
and stuff but it really it crushes it
love that thank you you're welcome okay
our first story of the day is like
really awkward okay Keke Palmer's
boyfriend is shaming her for wearing a
risque outfit to an usher concert so
Keke Palmer's boyfriend and father of
her son Darius Jackson seemingly shaded
her for wearing a sexy outfit to Usher's
Las Vegas residency show he said it's
the outfit though you a mom then he
tweeted to explain and clarify and kind
of like double down because people were
quite like a second he went out people
were like what the [__] literally and he
said
um let me get the full quote one second
there
is me
no you want to find out yeah
it was like it was giving like very
toxic masculine
yeah okay here's okay he said we live in
a generation where a man of the family
doesn't want the wife and mother to his
kids to Showcase booty cheeks to please
others and he gets told how much of a
hater he is this is my family and my
representation I have standards and
morals to what I believe I rest my case
listen you can have standards and morals
all you [__] want but you go on a
public platform especially when you know
the girl your girlfriend is like a major
celebrity like that's where this is
becoming problematic you want to have
these conversations behind closed doors
whether I think you're right or wrong
that's your prerogative sure the whole
public thing and I just want to say I
never saw an outfit so [__] cute as
to what Kiki Palmer was wearing she was
wearing basically like um it was a body
suit it was like a strapless bodysuit
black that really hugged her curves like
made her boobs look amazing with this um
sheer dress over maxi dress maxi dress I
went to the floor and it was long
sleeves it really wasn't that crazy no
as far as the crazy things that people
wear especially celebrities this is not
even that crazy
um and then she kind of responded she
posted a series of pictures from the
evening saying I wish I had taken more
pictures but we were running late I'm
telling y'all right now if you haven't
seen Usher you must go he was so
fabulous everyone's talking about Usher
by the way like his concert his
residency I'm sure it was really good I
think you really forget like how many
bangers Usher has yeah but we have this
conversation a few months ago in Florida
remember if you're
these are my confessions yeah so Kiki's
just being a queen about it to me it's
so weird that he posted this on social
media it makes me feel like they are not
together this is something an
ex-boyfriend would do right but then he
also called her his wife which she's not
right also I just find I was shocked by
this whole story because Kiki is such
like an outspoken like independent
person I feel like she needs to write a
book I think she's like been through a
lot like when she was a child star and
stuff so
I just find it shocking that you would
be with someone who kind of like
minimizes her I found this whole thing
so confusing and I didn't I knew she had
a boyfriend who like wasn't famous who
was because when she got pregnant I was
like wait does she even have a boyfriend
so I know that she's in a relationship
with like you know somebody less famous
than her or not famous at all
um but I never thought much about their
relationship but now I am and I'm like
ew yeah he's giving like like a red flag
that he would take to social media to
shame her that's like something that a
hater does like you're a mom you're
better than that and I agree with you
he's entitled to like his opinion sure
whatever what he's entitled to like what
he wants in a relationship and from his
partner but like leave us out of it and
like don't imbal that's so embarrassing
for her I know it was I was shocked I
was indeed at the end of the day like we
said like this outfit actually isn't
that crazy especially like for a night
out in Vegas with your girl Technically
she's like literally where her she's
covered from head to toe and the dress
goes to her wrists it's long sleeve and
down to the floor up to the neck yeah so
it's just a it's not that crazy of a
thing to wear be like
why can't anything be private anymore
like okay you want to have a fight with
your wife sure like why do we have to be
here yeah I feel like
they can't be in a good place right now
if this is what's happening or maybe
they're not together I don't know she
like just gave birth I really don't know
she also is very private about her
relationship which is why I think her um
pregnancy announcement was so shocking
yeah and I think also why her response
is just so glazing over the situation
like she's not gonna give this air yeah
but you shouldn't be like having to
you know get in PR crisis mode from your
own partner no like when the call is
coming from inside the house it's a
problem like being a public figure is
hard enough with like all these scandals
and people trolling you and backlash
whatever so for your own partner to be
starting stuff oh for me deal breaker
yeah if Ben ever [__] said anything
even remotely trolley like publicly
[__] you're sitting outside you're
swimming in the hallway I'm not talking
for a month yeah if he if you like went
to Vegas and you're wearing something
like sexy sexy
and he said
I'm sorry your Theo's mom
yeah I would literally I don't but the
thing is like it's so unbelievable that
it would be funny it's so unbelievable
because Bennett's always like take your
shirt off like show some skin no it
would be like oh Ben's being funny yeah
like haha
LOL
no Darius isn't being funny though
because he doubled down oh with this
whole thing about yeah well he has
morals and Sanders is it to say like the
rest of us don't Kiki doesn't okay now
this might be like an incredibly like
weird reference but what does this
remind you of Naya Rivera Naya Rivera
it's literally word for word what naira
Vera said to Kim I'm sorry but you're a
mom yeah like okay and yeah objection
relevance
what moms can be sexy look at Jackie O
in that jumpsuit okay please jumpsuit is
the epitome it's very revealing
according to Darius it's just as
revealing as Kiki Palmer's outfit
maybe not
so this was a weird series of events
this was a weird series of events it
wasn't exactly how I expected to learn
the name of Kiki Palmer's boyfriend but
here we are Darius
all the best to them wishing them well
truly are you ready for our next story
kind of the big news of the day the
bnotd yeah threads yes all the
celebrities already using meta's Twitter
rival called threads so the app launched
yesterday I guess was supposed to launch
today it's called threads it's literally
Twitter but a different app the
interface looks exactly the same it's
connected through your Instagram it's
really easy to sign up yes I am on it I
actually got Early Access I was the
2000th person to join threads it's like
not a big deal or anything and what do
you have to show for that I have about
40 000 followers wow it's all
um imported from Instagram so like when
I joined it's like do you want to follow
everyone you follow on Instagram I'm
like sure so every time one of my
followers signs up it's like yeah sure
follow so it's kind of like easy if you
already have a platform which is why I
like it like I built my Instagram now
I'm a threads influencer too you know
but I do have a lot of thoughts the
interface is exactly the same it's
really the same purpose and I think you
know everyone being imported from their
real Instagrams makes it more um I feel
like I forget who I was having this
conversation with but it makes it more
um like accountable it's like a real
person you know it connects to their
Instagram and the thing about Twitter
what makes Twitter great but also scary
is the anonymity of it all like you
literally need to provide no information
to sign up and that's where like a lot
of like the most hilarious tweets come
from but it's also where like a lot of
like the really [__] mean ones and
like the doxing culture but there are
also finstas like you could have a
finsta and a Fred yes yes yes but I
think right now it's like everybody
who's on it right in this moment
everyone's signing up with their real
ones but it's just like anything else it
will become polluted with trash so right
now it's a little boring like everyone's
being like how great is this I'm like no
be mean no it's like not only but the
thing it's just a cycle it's just
Twitter 2.0 it's like I feel like just
like when people have to just like take
to share their thoughts like it kind of
just devolves into meanness sometimes I
know and that's how you get yourself
canceled no it's so true
I don't know like every like literally
everyone joined nanny no not Jackie but
like when I was on and I got on early
there was already like ever JLo like
everyone so
I think it's just really
whenever like a new app launches like
kind of like Clubhouse or
um be real or like lemon lemonade lemon
last week yeah it's always exciting like
the first week and everybody checks but
the real proof is in the longevity so
like say what you want about Twitter
it's been around forever it really is
like the go-to place for updates and
news and and all the people that I
follow on Instagram
I don't want to follow them on threads
necessarily I'm not following them for
their amazing thoughts and opinions like
I'm following because of gorgeous photos
right things that they're creating so I
don't think that it's a like in the
Twitter ecosystem already works because
the people who have something to say
have the follow like you know always new
people can come up but like the people
who are influential there are like
thought leaders and Instagram
influencers are not necessarily always
the thought leader yeah I think it'll
take like a while for everyone to like
like oh and the platform is is like very
beta and I saw Adam Mo sarri posted a
thing too like so excited that you're
all excited about threads please keep in
mind like this is you know really early
version like there's not even a a
following page like all my timeline is
not everyone I follow I'm like what the
[__] do I care about these people like I
never even heard of these people and
there's no um there's a lot of features
that aren't there yet so they launched
prematurely I know they did launch like
24 hours early but there's still like a
lot of features missing so I it might be
like one of those cases where people get
like fed up where the platform's like so
beta it's a con I don't know what it
means means for Twitter there's pros and
cons for me like I think some of like
the most you know people on Twitter who
have like a ton of followers are like
literally some of the worst people on
the [__] planet so like I like love
that they have to start over you know
um I'd like that it's connected to
Instagram just selfishly like I like
that I already have 40 000 followers and
I've literally posted one thing so there
are things that I like about it but then
there are things that like roll my eyes
out are you gonna post it on it yeah
like if I have a thought like a funny
joke and and threads is going to be the
place where you go you're not gonna make
a real or a tick tock well or post your
Instagram story I haven't had a Twitter
in years so whenever I've had a funny
thought I've made it into a piece of
content for Instagram or Tick Tock and
that's really worked well for me so now
I need to start factoring in Threads
into my social media strategy yeah
I don't know I'm not sure it's not it's
not clear yet whether this is going to
be like completely ubiquitous take over
Twitter you know everyone's like Twitter
so ever since Elon bought it I'm I have
we have a toast Twitter and I'm always
scrolling Twitter just like to see what
the t is
um it remains completely unchanged
people are like it's been like shitty
since Elon I've had no problems and I
use it every day I think just people
like hate Elon and they just want to rag
on it it literally is the same
um
so I don't know I don't know
very interesting it'll be interesting to
see how it develops I feel like the one
of the biggest things that people don't
like about Elon is like his
um
stance on like sensors on Free Speech
exactly so I wonder like eventually
threads if it's meant to be exactly like
Twitter like is gonna have to confront
like censorship and meta actually has a
pretty strong track record of censoring
so then maybe that's the the old Twitter
well maybe it's like maybe
maybe now you have two options yeah like
maybe both can coexist maybe both um
maybe
it'll be interesting I feel like right
now everyone's running to it no one
wants to be left behind yeah
uh I'm
I just don't really care right now and
I like where that's why everyone's on it
like everyone's whenever like a new app
people always join it just in case it
becomes the next Tick Tock yeah and
either it takes off or people just
slowly stop using it we don't know yet
and also everything now is like hey this
is threads cool everyone's like well hi
guys this is my threads and then they're
posting it like to their Instagram I'm
like well this needs to stop yeah no I'm
not on Instagram to see like hey guys
what's up your threads yeah it's giving
like when they launched status updates
well that was like a major flop that we
don't talk about enough when Instagram
did the first week I was like what is
this and people and then people would be
like you know going to the mall and like
I will have some days where I have zero
status updates from the people I follow
like there's nothing there oh I've never
seen one
really yeah I'm pretty sure my answer I
told you girl no job is like literally
always the last person on Instagram to
get I never got the the status update
feature but I got it on Claude with no
job and there's like two people I follow
who always have one up yeah it's a weird
thing so jury's out yeah we'll have to
wait and see what this means for the
social Stratosphere I don't think it
will really mean anything for Twitter in
a meaningful way but I do think that it
could be its own thing of like and
here's where the instagramers go to put
their thoughts right okay
as if there's like not enough places
right
so we'll just have to wait and see what
this one yeah
our next story there's a Barney movie
coming out starring Daniel kaluya and it
will be a play for adults yeah I read
something about this so Daniel kalia's
upcoming Barney movie will not be family
friendly as the release of Barbie which
stars Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling
nears Mattel Mattel films is sharing
more about its other upcoming projects
including the film about everyone's
favorite purple dinosaur in an interview
with the New Yorker Kevin McKeon an
executive for the toy Focus brand said
that the movie will be surrealistic
comparing it to the films of
screenwriter directors Charlie Kaufman
and Spike Jones so they did Anna Melissa
I'm thinking of ending things and her
adaptation well Daniel caluya was also
get out right it's like a spooky but
he's an actor he doesn't yeah it's true
true he also shared that the Target
demographic of the Barney film will not
be that far an age from the original
audience of the dinosaurs hit show
Barney and Friends the kids program ran
from 1992 to 2000 nine he said we're
leaning into the millennial angst of the
property rather than fine-tuning this
for kids it's really a play for adults
not that it's R-rated but it'll focus on
some of the trials and tribulations of
being 30-something growing up with
Barney just the level of disenchantment
within the generation what the [__] does
that like seriously they've told us what
the movie's about what is it about like
what is it I have done a documentary
idea
I have no idea honestly it will be
surrealistic what does that mean let's
see so at first I thought it was gonna
be like a horror movie where like Barney
goes and like murders a bunch of kids in
the woods or something no it sounds like
I have no idea no it's like very
confusing surrealistic is having a
strange dream like atmosphere or quality
like that of a surrealist painting
Webster you're not supposed to use the
word in the definition but okay now
you're coming from Miriam sorry this
sounds horrible it does sound horrible
um and like don't compare yourself to
Barbie you know no but it's Mattel no I
get it but like they're obviously using
the momentum of Barbie to like make some
press for their losery movie don't no
zones so bizarre I can't even I can't
even imagine I can't even fathom what it
is what is it and the fact that it's
like Barney for adults is everyone okay
you know and like the way you've done a
whole interview with telling us what the
movie is and we still don't get it
that's not a good sign yeah but I do
want to say I am like so here for the
Resurgence of Barney you know we had the
Barney dock you know the Dark Side of
Barney
um Barney was a cultural icon like
really a real Cornerstone of the
Zeitgeist and so for him to be slowly
being brought back that I'm totally here
for yes like Barney is a pajam yeah I
think kids these days need Barney we
grew up on Barney we loved Barney oh my
God we were obsessed a few times I've
like put on some old Barney on YouTube
like for Harry and it still hits like it
slaps the songs are good clean up clean
up everybody everywhere everybody do
your share yeah and it's a good message
wow and that's crazy because to me
that's like a ubiquitous song like years
now what has it been 20 years since
Barney I feel like they use that song at
every preschool yeah I mean maybe it
came from somewhere else but to me and
like the way I remember it it's
popularized by Barney
would love to do okay you know there's
like a Barbie soundtrack yeah I would
love to get like
maybe Fall Out Boy to do like a punk
rock clean up clean up everybody like
love that Simple Plan maybe yeah Panic
at the Disco even though they're
splitting up yeah like they're done
Tata TTFN tata for now
so
so I I have no words
we'll just have to wait and see this is
kind of the episode of like waiting and
seeing waiting and seeing though I will
not be seeing this I can tell you no I
no like I I'm dying to see Barbie and I
probably won't even see it you know like
I'm definitely not seeing Barney no not
especially if it's a surrealist for like
distressed Millennials who are having a
hard time being a 30-something like no
honestly using the and I know we say
Millennials every morning but like using
Millennials in a non-ironic way in the
description of this movie is like a
Surefire way to get me to not see it no
and catering to something leaning into
Millennial angst
what the [__] do Millennials have to
complain about
I don't know are you okay no like I'm
just is this story giving you heartburn
she's just like no yeah it's gonna be a
no from us but you know good luck on
your project yeah perhaps
are you ready for our next story is it
the story that's brought to you by seed
perhaps yes all right well if you
struggle with any sort of gut issues if
you've been wanting to get into a
Prebiotic check out seed they're ds01
daily symbiotic is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with a 24 strain
that has been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
so it's free from 14 classes of
allergens defined by the efsa and more
including sugar-free vegan soy-free
Sesame free gluten-free peanut free
dairy free shellfish free all the freeze
and you know there's a lot of options
out there and here's where you should
choose seed because it's engineered to
survive it survives your external and
internal environments it's their capsule
and capsulin Via cap safeguard that
makes sure um your what you're taking is
viable through digestion a lot of times
you'll take a probiotic a Prebiotic and
it literally won't make its way down
your digestive tract but seed make sure
that it has an average of 100 percent
of their probiotic starting dose to your
colon the outer capsule also serves as
an elegant barrier for oxygen moisture
and heat so there's a many many benefits
to taking seed you know digestive health
of course big soft duties we love skin
health so they're uh they have four
specific probiotic strains that have
been shown to promote healthy skin and
reinforce a healthy gut skin access
also a great another great benefit of
taking seed is heart health you can
maintain blood cholesterol levels that
are already in the normal range and it
supports healthy intestinal recycling of
cholesterol and bile so seed delivers
the dso1 daily symbiotic to you monthly
in sustainable packaging with a reusable
glass jar that protects the probiotics
inside and helps minimize plastic use
and waste all right so if you want to
start getting on that probiotic train
check out seed
we uh of course have a deal for you if
you want to redeem 30 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic go
to seed.com toast that's code toast at
seed.com toast code toast
[Music]
you sound like a Hannah Montana
transition
yeah you know how people have like music
transitions between ads yeah when the
show starts we should like start adding
we should rip some of the Hannah sounds
yeah that would be so funny iconic let's
do it let's do it what are the other
ones I keep seeing the same one
[Music]
oh yeah okay we have one more ad break
today right yeah so we'll put it in this
episode for that ad break I said
something for you guys to look forward
to yeah for you Millennial angsty
Millennials out there
all right our next story some
Star-Crossed Stars chakra Stars Honey
Boo Boo's dad will be checking into
Lamar Odom's rehab facility for
prescription drug addiction so is Honey
Boo Boo's dad sugar bear sugar bear
Sugar Bear Hair sugar bear Thompson is
seeking help for an addiction and he's
turning to one of Lamar Odom's rehab
centers for treatment we reported like a
few months ago that Lamar Odom had
opened his own rehab centers Oh I
thought you meant a facility that Lamar
went to I'm like why do we care oh okay
now I understand why the story is
relevant relevant
objection relevance sources close to
Sugar Bear Hair tell TMZ that he reached
out
it's really hard not to not to say sugar
bear hair I just want to say I love
sugar bear
yeah
he reached out I'm trying to remember
the one who got the show canceled I
don't think so I think it was one of
Mama June's boyfriends yeah who was like
acting inappropriately he reached out to
Lamar over the weekend about going to
one of his treatment centers and on
Thursday evening he will check into a
facility in Kansas to focus on his
recovery TMZ has told Honey Boo Boo's
dad is hooked on prescription jugs he
started taking as part of his diabetes
treatment and he also has severe
depression and anxiety the sources say
that Sugar Bear first met Lamar last
summer through their manager and they've
since established a friendship which led
him to start rehab at the Gold Bridge
gold Bridge Treatment Center in
Lewisburg part of the Odom Recovery
Group okay I love this I don't know how
these two connected but the fact that
they did and like were able to help each
like find each other I'm like in a cry
this is so sweet it's so sweet I'm glad
that sugar bear has someone that he
could turn to and I'm also like happy
for them he's found his purpose no
totally
I'm like this is so unexpected right
across Stars I know like I wouldn't if
you had like said to me how do these two
know each other like I never would have
paired these two but I'm so you know sad
for sugar bear that he's been going
through this and I'm glad that Lamar
could be there for him in his time of
need yeah and I'm glad that he's getting
the help that he needs and has like you
know turned himself to treatment
honestly I think like a Honey Boo Boo
family documentary like is like this
family has been through a lot and I
don't watch any of their current like
shows I know they have some shows and
they're like all the girls are like
rebelling against Mama June like there's
a lot going on in the Booboo universe
and Honey Boo Boo is not speaking with
her dad with sugar bear right now she's
they're not on speaking to her she
wasn't from at her graduation that's so
sad
um the estrangement could be tied to his
addiction the sources say that he's
hoping that he can mend fences with his
daughter once he's completed his rehab
stay oh
this is the family like I genuinely wish
the best for like they if you were there
like during the TLC years before their
show got canceled because Mama June was
dating a predator
um but before that like it was literally
the best show on TV the fact that it was
in English and the whole show had
subtitles was like one of my favorite
Parts yeah because they were talking so
fast and so country like you literally
could not understand a word that came
out of their mouths Yeah but I I watch
everything with subtitles these days so
do I was just having that conversation
with a bunch of my friends like that's a
part of growing up like you know you're
getting old when you officially watch
everything with subtitles yeah
like I can't compute I can no longer
watch and listen at the same time
I don't know I think it's just because a
couple shows that we've watched like
you've needed subtitles if you want to
like really get every ounce of
information like Game of Thrones yeah
succession and then it's like oh well
this isn't uh elevated experience yes
but then there are some shows I cannot
watch subtitles with like oh because
it's moronic like like yes like I don't
watch Housewives I don't watch any
reality shows with subtitles because
they barely say anything of substance
I'm not gonna miss anything yeah also I
do feel like with reality TV and this
just might be like I might be wrong but
I feel like because it's not scripted
they don't have the script to plug into
the subtitles and sometimes it's not 100
yes at least with like you know
succession it's like they have the
script and this is the exact word that
was intended yeah but even the
succession subtitles were infuriating
stutters
thinking like it's so unpleasant no but
like you know exactly what they're
trying to say whereas with reality TV
like sometimes
they they just misinterpret them yeah
and like Game of Thrones there's so much
like dialogue and information in that
dialogue you really do need the
subtitles but there's not you know crazy
substantial conversations being had on
housewives and that's why I like it yeah
agreed a good are you ready for our
fifth and final story some business news
that's pertinent to everyone that I
hadn't heard yet what
Bed Bath and Beyond will be bought Oh by
overstock.com oh and overstock.com will
change their website name to Bed Bath
and Beyond you know I'll become one I
don't think like as a society we really
ever spoke about enough how bad of a
brand name Overstock was yeah like how
ugly like oh I love your uh your shae's
Lounge where's it from Overstock like
it's so disgusting overstock.com right I
couldn't even get myself to the store
what a gorgeous you know Persian silk
rug you have wherever did you find that
overstock.com no and they actually do
have really nice things yes and they
like it does fit Under the Umbrella of
bed and bath and beyond right Bed Bath
and Beyond I feel like we've been
talking about the demise of Bed Bath
Beyond for two [__] years like first
up is bankruptcy then it was like
they're back and then it was all the
stores closing and now they're getting
bought like they're kind of being
dramatic like just figure it out and
leave us alone no but I'm happy that
there will be like a next chapter for
them because I think it's a really great
brand Overstock will not be buying this
stores though this is just like an
e-commerce deal and they're buying
pretty much the name for 21.5 million
dollars which sounds a little bit like
they're just buying the name and like
the digital assets no I get it but like
that definitely sucks because I was like
a big bed Bethany on customer and I've
never once placed an order on their
website it was always on like I'm going
to camp for the summer I'm packing for
college I'm moving Apartments I'm going
to bed bath beyond and spending at least
two thousand dollars like for everything
I could possibly need yeah but
now they're not even having stores
Overstock has really good online
presence they're all online and they
have good shipping and Bed Bath and
Beyond has really good brand recognition
I actually think this is
a love match okay they're not buying bye
bye baby I'm like upset about Bye Bye
Baby going out I feel like so many times
I turned to buy my baby like oh I need a
stroller I got it from bye bye baby I
feel like bye bye baby is more relevant
and you know successful than Bed Bath
and Beyond a couple of bidders have
expressed interest in buying the Bye Bye
Baby should buy it but it remains
unclear if any will be bought no I don't
think they need the stores
no but like I there's a store in the
city and like so many times like when I
first had Harry it was like they could
do same-day delivery and like that's
where I would go to I don't know why I
would rather buy it from like Buy Baby
than Amazon right I just felt like if it
was in bye-bye baby like it was the
goods yeah if it's on Amazon you get you
could pick from anything I really feel
like bye bye baby like should be bought
by Amazon
the same way they bought like Whole
Foods oh I guess and you can do like
pick up from Amazon same day at a Whole
Foods you could buy your stroller and
it'll be at your local Buy Buy Baby in
30 minutes you know please somebody
needs to say bye bye baby I know the
moms like they need it we do like a
store dedicated to Baby Tang because
there's like not no but before there's
like baby boutiques and like whatever
but like something that sells everything
you could possibly need for like newborn
everything yeah and like every brand
pretty much like I know Bloomingdale's
has the baby floor and they have
strollers bassinets cribs whatever but
like they have like three of each right
no you need the Amazon for motherhood
and that's bye bye baby and Amazon needs
to Buy Buy Baby but also we need brick
and mortar because sometimes you just
want to run to the store that's what I'm
saying is that exactly what Amazon did
with Whole Foods they didn't close down
all the Whole Foods yes and Whole Foods
run very efficiently now yeah
I'm telling you free idea Jeff free idea
bye bye baby is a great brand yeah
so anyways we'll see what happens with
Overstock and Bed Bath and Beyond but
now Overstock will be called Bed Bath
and Beyond so that's a confusing it is
but I think it makes sense no and I'm
still here for the Overstock Rebrand
like one of the worst names like the
fact that they made it that they're so
successful
and you know what I actually feel like
Wayfair kind of eclipsed over stock
Overstock has been around I feel longer
than Wayfair but wayfared like
wayfarer's shipping is literally like
Amazon level yeah but I don't associate
the two as the same like but I'm going
to Wayfair for something it's not like I
it's not what I would be going to
Overstock or something I'm still
Furniture but like when I'm going away
for like I know it's gonna be like
kind of cheap not that great but like oh
I disagree it's gonna it's gonna solve
the problem I disagree Overstock like
you could really get nice pieces yeah
but like the thing is
are they even overstocked items like
they're not it's such a misleading title
No but it makes you feel like you're
getting savings yes yes I guess that's
true and I do feel like I'm getting
savings I don't know what savings I've
forgotten but right but it feels that
way right well I just think Overstock
needs to step their [__] up and they
are they are losing to the Wayfarers the
all moderns of the world right but what
Overstock has that Wayfair does not have
is you know no one's wondering if
they're trafficking children yeah okay
and that's just kind of like a cloud
that hangs over Wayfair yeah but the
what a lot of people don't know about
Wayfair is that they're part of like a
family of Brands they're like they're
technically the same companies like
allmodern.com and Johnson Maine Johnson
Maine and they're all different price
points but they're literally all the
same crap like it's actually really
smart how they have like different like
websites for different price points but
they're all coming from the same like
Factory
um
so they really have it all because I
would consider like all modern on the
same level as Overstock I don't go there
I go to Wayfair yeah
they have it all
right and they have the trafficking but
what Wayfair does have that nobody else
has is Kelly Clarkson as their
spokesperson
you see those commercials where she gets
in bed with those old people and starts
singing
uh no but I've seen her associated with
Wayfair well she has a Furniture line on
Wayfair while also being a spokesperson
she's in all their commercials yeah and
they're like hey you're Kelly Clarkson
yeah but you could really get anything
on Wayfair it's crazy no a child
no no that was a joke but like you
really can't get anything yeah they like
I get these targeted ads for like some
of the more random products that they
have especially like for kids and stuff
like play water parks yeah you can
literally have a water park in your
backyard no I for Michaela's birthday I
got her like the sickest playground from
Wayfair yeah she hasn't set it up yet
rude all right uh those were the Fast
Five
you definitely needed to know them
topical varied and random definitely
random definitely varied definitely
topical
we do what we can
um but the show's not over yet because
it's Thursday which should mean nothing
but today it means everything because
deer toasters are weekly advice segment
is coming on right now
break for Hannah who I wasn't done like
okay fine
yeah today's episode is brought to you
by game time buying tickets to your
favorite event should not be stressful
yet here we are but game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the fun
you'll have so game time is the place
for last minute ticket deals forget
planning months in advance game time is
deals on tickets right up to the day of
the event you can get exclusive Flash
Deals on tickets from football baseball
basketball concerts comedy theater and
more the game time guarantee also means
you'll always get the best price so if
you find tickets in the same section and
row for Less game time will credit you
not a hundred percent
110 percent of the difference it's the
fastest growing ticket app in the
country for a reason get images of
receipts before you buy so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive
buy tickets in a matter of seconds two
Taps and you're all set tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email so whether you
live in a fabulous town with lots of
events going on or you're traveling to a
fabulous Town you're just traveling in
general you want to do something
fabulous it's so great to always have
the game time app just download it on
your phone you know find yourself in
Charlotte go to a Bobcats game the
possibilities are endless they also have
tickets to the Eris tour when I was on
uh looking for error story tickets game
time had snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
toast for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again you have to create an
account redeemed with code toast and
you'll get twenty dollars off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price
guaranteed guaranteed dear toasters is
also brought to you by impossible Foods
so it's grilling season it's summer
season and not all of us want to harm
the planet you know not all of us want
to consume meat whatever reason you
might have summer grilling is here and
impossible Foods is here for you
impossible Foods once you and your grill
to join them in making meat history so
as you may or may not know impossible
beef is delicioso it tastes like beef
and historically speaking beef is
delicious but it's made from Plants
impossible has zero animal hormones and
19 grams of protein per serving and it's
better for the planet where would the
planet be without meat made from plants
so so obviously it's like summer
grilling season and I feel like
everyone's trying to cut down on their
meat intake impossible food is me I love
their beef but all their products are so
good I actually just had an impossible
beef burrito on a Delta flight and me
and Margo I don't know we're going to
the acms we scarfed that whole thing
down it was so delicious it really
tasted like authentic beef and then I
didn't have like a beef brick in my
stomach you know like I felt so much
better it was so good it's better for
the planet so and we all need kosher
beef so whether it's not Kosher options
impossible is a great option you've
never been able to have a beef burrito
on a flight right because I'm just not
privileged like that right but
impossible beef is out here so start
making meat history today head over to
the meat aisle at your local store grab
some impossible beef or patties and get
grilling girl it's hot girl summer Hot
Grill summer all right ready for deer
toaster Sorry by segment where we help
toasters in need every Wednesday but
today we're doing Thursday yeah so if
you want to submit our submissions are
all Anonymous you don't have to worry
about it there are two ways to submit
you can just simply email your
submission to deertoesters gmail.com or
you can head over to our website
thetoastpodcast.com scroll down and
there's a deer toaster submission box
totally Anonymous we'll never know where
it came from no worries we've got three
really good ones today ready
hey girlies I've been married for eight
years and I have three kids yesterday my
husband decided to tell me he finds me
extremely unattractive because of all
the mosquito bites I get some I get on
my legs in the summer he doesn't want to
have sex certain ways because of it
trust me I'm attractive so I wasn't
offended at first but now I'm just
stewing I'm a stay-at-home mom we have a
big yard it's summer I'm outside with
the kids all the time things will get me
and I don't want to drown myself in
chemicals every day so am I crazy to
think that this is rude or anyone have
any natural mosquito repellent
suggestions so I can have sex in certain
positions okay what the [__] this isn't
a thing there's something else
completely going on mosquito bites I
mean first of all look at my legs I'm
covered in bruise fig spray at the fake
tan and mosquito bites and literally I
don't think Ben I could have literally
my calf could be cut off and if we're
having sex Ben wouldn't even notice so
this is not a thing there's something
I've had in mosquito bites that look
like welds so like maybe let's say it's
about the mosquito bites okay you know
they're married eight years hopefully
they can like say how they feel to each
other I don't know like turn the [__]
lights off if it bothers you like and
the fact that he would even vocalize
that it's so delusional it's so nuts he
needs to be spoken to partially the
thing is like I don't buy you I don't
think that you should make any
accommodations you shouldn't turn off
the lights you shouldn't wear mosquito
repellent you can turn off the lights no
no how about that no but if he had just
turned off the lights before he
complained about it like we would have
never known no but now that you know
like you have every right to be offended
I don't think you should make any sort
of accommodations to make him feel
better he seriously he's unwell yeah you
need to lay into him and be like I'm
with the kids all day every day I have
mosquito bites I'm sorry I'm working so
hard to raise our children and like I'm
willing to have sex with you oh right
you're welcome right and at least it's
summer I'm not sitting in the house
letting the kids watch TV 24 7. they're
out of school and I'm still challenging
them and getting them physical activity
[__] all the way off he needs his ass
written down and then say I don't want
to have sex with you because you have a
reamed ass yeah okay you need to rip him
a new [__] and then you need to be
like your [__] is weird I'm kind of
unattracted to you so I don't think we
should be having sex until you get that
fixed but your [__] is ripped yeah
it's kind of gross
yikes it's just Stern talking to no this
screams toxic like there's in no way
shape or form is even remotely okay
thing to say yeah for sure but like
they're married eight years they have
three kids like this is they could be
honest with one I get it no no that's
not what I'm saying I'm just saying like
Okay it's it's not a good it's a red
flag but like
we're past red flags no it's not a deal
breaker I'm saying but like you need to
literally annihilate this man like he
needs to be destroyed emotionally he
needs to be destroyed like you like you
actually you need to make him cry like
that's how you need him to make him feel
so he's so bad about himself that he's
someone that would say such a thing and
think such the mother of his children
the mother of his children whose crime
is running around outside with her kids
all day right like if anything those
mosquito bites should make him hard as a
[__] rock oh yeah that's my wife
taking such good care of the kids while
I'm out all day running around getting
my kids active in fresh air oh I'm gonna
come that's what he should be saying
yeah dick
ah sick so make him cry that's kind of
the that's the the lesson here but this
isn't like you know a deal breaker of
any sorts sometimes men just like really
need to be yelled at yes sometimes
people need to be put in their place
yeah like people get carried away about
one thing or another yeah
and sometimes they just like say things
without realizing like How Deeply
hurtful they are because they seem like
innocuous you know but they're not this
literally happened to me in bed like
literally last week he said something
totally like it wasn't that big of a
deal but like
once I explained like why what he said I
don't want to say it because like
because whatever it will sound bad no no
no it won't sound bad at all but I don't
wanna I'll tell you but like I whatever
it's so stupid I'm like whatever you're
entitled to your pride so once I
explained it he was like oh my God that
was like so [__] up with me to say
like they just need to be outside yeah
yeah no and just like
see your POV it happens all the time
yeah all right next up these next two
are like really bizarre hey Jackson
Claude I recently found out that my
fiance got a girl pregnant in college it
was someone he dated for two years and
they decided together to not go through
the pregnancy I know it might not be any
of my business giving this given the
sensitivities on the topic but I can't
believe he never brought this up before
I find myself wanting to ask more
questions about the girl and the
circumstances of the decision but I'm
not sure how much I can pry anyway love
you bye how did she find out I don't
know he must have told her but like no
but she's saying like she doesn't want
she feels like she can't bring it up she
I feel like she found out not for me no
she said I can't believe he never
brought this up before Oh
um I don't know I feel like it's the
sort of thing that you tell someone like
when the conversation comes up it's not
something that like you have to disclose
right there hasn't been like a prior
conversation about it but it is
something that you should have a
conversation about and whenever he did
bring it up
um I feel like you could have asked more
questions and even now you could be like
you know I've been thinking about what
you told me I appreciate you sharing it
with me I just like and then ask your
questions yeah I know what you're
feeling though it's just this weird
thing where like you spend your life
with someone but there's like 20 years
or however old there are when you meet
them like of life that they lived
without you and when you find something
out like even Ben like every now and
then we've been together for 10 years
every now and then I will find something
out like crazy or just like random from
his childhood or whatever and I'm like
it's the weirdest feeling to not know
because like you you're supposed to know
this person better than anyone yeah you
really can't know everything about
everyone even though this is a big thing
this is a big thing they're engaged so
it's not like they're you know you're
finding out this like secret about your
husband like I feel like it's an okay
time for it to be coming up and I do
feel like you should ask your questions
and like Circle back to the subject and
be me like have whatever conversation
you need to have to feel more
comfortable about like the whole thing
yeah and you might end up like you know
learning things about your partner that
make you really like him like he was
really there for the girl and took care
of her and you know whatever like he
made me maybe maybe he'll end up being
the hero of the story you know yeah
you'll end up just finding things out
like you're really proud of him how he
handled it you know yeah you never know
but yeah ask all your questions I think
that's fair to like pester with
questions to Circle back on it no and I
wouldn't like get I wouldn't harp on the
fact that he didn't tell you like I
don't know fiance actually
whatever just it's not a big deal you
know I could see if it like if the if
the topic can never come up really
how it might have slipped through the
cracks in a non-nefarious way yeah
yeah because you don't want to be
talking about your old Partners like in
your new relationship right
I would let it go but ask all the
questions you are but don't be mad yeah
don't like and don't have feelings or
thoughts about it that you feel like you
can't share like let it out yeah and
move forward all right our third and
final dear toasters hey Jackson Claude
my husband and I are expecting our first
child and we just found out it's a girl
we tried for about a year and we are
over the moon excited we started
discussing names recently
and my husband informed me that he wants
to name her after his high school
girlfriend first love who tragically
passed away their senior year
while I understand the sentiment I do
not want to name her that his mother
just told me to settle with a middle
name but that is so weird to me what do
I do
that's really hard I know
um but it's like your decision yeah no
and if you don't like the like if that
doesn't work for you whether it's you
don't like the name or you don't like
the
meaning behind it
I don't think the meaning is bad maybe
you guys could go with that letter right
do you like the name
it sounds like no okay
um it's a weird feeling to feel like
threatened by a person who's like dead
but like again I don't feel like it's a
threatening thing I think it's like one
it would be like a constant reminder two
who knows if she has people she wants to
name for that like
our first born daughter like like I
understand why this is not for you I do
feel like it would be really nice if you
could find like a small way to honor her
but at the end of the day like you're
the mother like it is your call don't
worry like you can do what you want yeah
in the hospital like they're gonna let
you sign the paperwork you know yeah and
like you're doing all the work so if you
don't like it by the end of all of the
like by the time you know babies here
and everything like you're not gonna
feel bad about whatever decision you
need no and like I feel like if you want
to compromise this is a perfect example
of like you know marriage is a
compromise all right so let's say her
name was Lauren you don't have to name
her baby Lauren but why don't you have
the baby's middle name be Leah you know
yeah start with an out that's okay the
first letter but like middle name if you
even want to do that if it's the
firstborn in your family I feel like
there's so many people and your
grandparents Aunts Uncles whoever like
who you want to honor with the name but
it also doesn't sound like that's what
it is I mean that would be like a good
excuse to have if you were having
something like that but also I
understand like you guys you not wanting
this this does sound like something that
would happen in like one of my novels
you know like he meets a girl and he's
so closed off because his first love
tragically passed away and you know this
new girl slowly prices open makes him
prize him up and makes him believe in
love and then they realize they're
pregnant and you know they name the baby
yeah but in the epilogue but it's like
everyone's happy that the name yeah but
that [__] doesn't happen in real life it
doesn't have to be that way yeah no I
don't think you have to do it like by
any means especially if like you don't
want to which it sounds like you don't
yeah I think that's fine
um
but that's awkward yeah it's definitely
weird yeah well those were your toasters
our weekly advice segment please email
us dear toasters gmail.com or head over
to the toastpodcast.com to submit your
Anonymous submissions and we'll do our
best to help you out through whatever
you know Minefield you found yourself in
and that's our show that is our show
thank you for watching thank you for
listening check out the redheads and
pre-order my children's book the camper
and the council are available now
anywhere you pre-order it's not
available now available now for
pre-order anywhere you pre-order books
and what does it come out Jax October
10th and what kind of feelings will I
feel when I read this gorgeous novel
Novella I'll feel
really warm and fuzzy nostalgic
nostalgic for sure and emotional
emotional yeah well thank you so much
for listening to the testimony Morning
Show where we deliver the fastest
stories that you need to know everybody
on YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
this video thumbs up also available
I guess myself bye